[Music]
[Applause]
got to show you this waiting thing
you're being honored he will be
presented with a Lifetime Achievement
Award so what this holder Maris is 24/7
driving slate for the entire weekend
look who the previous winners are Robert
DeNiro attract Nicholson and Clint
Eastwood what yeah you should see this
rat hole you're there already just what
the hell is this this is the festival
welcome to Nashville we are to have you
here how are ya thank you for coming to
the film festival let's get you over the
red carpet
[Music]
but how are you even here because it's
Clinton Jack and Bobby general hot ones
you are the only one stupid enough to
show up there are things I've go where's
Vic you left Vic washed
yo bang bang oh my god I'm tired of
feeling like a has been the number one
box office star for five years in a row
six six I'm sorry better choice to take
the next action takes on different
where are you guys he's on some weird
memory tour or something guy who you are
is it true that you doubled Burt
Lancaster had to double somebody on that
picture I had a fall off a horse up in a
dress an audience for forgive a shitty
act - she's been well in Act three
The Hollywood Critics Association
awarded you best newcomer of the year
that's the only time I ever agreed with
the critic
[Music]